hey this is presh tallwalker
suppose alpha beta and gamma are roots
of the equation
x cubed plus three x squared minus 24x
plus one is equal to zero
find the value
of the cube root of alpha plus the cube
root of beta plus the cube root of gamma
i thank avinash for the suggestion
this is a textbook problem
in preparation for the jee advanced
which is famously one of india's hardest
tests
i want to show you step by step how to
solve this problem
so here's one way that we can figure it
out
we will first examine the cubic equation
there are no simple roots like x is
equal to 0 x is equal to 1 or x is equal
to negative 1.
there's also no obvious way to factor
the cubic equation
so we want to think about other patterns
that might come to mind
in this case the cubic equation
resembles x cubed plus 3x squared plus
3x plus 1 which is equal to the cube of
the sum x plus
1. so let's transform the original
equation by adding 27x to both sides
the left-hand side then becomes x cubed
plus 3x squared plus 3x plus 1 and the
right-hand side is
the left hand side factors
we can then take the cube root of both
sides and the cube root of 27 is equal
to 3.
so if x plus 1 is equal to 3 times the
cube root of x
now alpha beta and gamma are roots of
the original equation which means they
satisfy this equation as well
alpha plus one is equal to three times
the cube root of alpha
beta plus one is equal to three times
the cube root of beta and gamma plus one
is equal to three times the cube root of
gamma
let's now sum these three equations
together
we get alpha plus beta plus gamma plus
three
is equal to three times the cube root of
alpha plus three times the cube root of
beta plus three times the cube root of
gamma
let's factor the right hand side and
then divide both sides by three
so we're making good progress
we now just need to figure out the sum
of alpha beta and gamma
but we can do that
from the original equation we know that
negative the coefficient on the second
highest term divided by the coefficient
on the highest term will be equal to the
sum of the roots
the roots are alpha beta and gamma so we
have alpha plus beta plus gamma is equal
to the opposite of three over one which
is equal to negative three
so alpha plus beta plus gamma is equal
to negative three
we can substitute that in and then we
have negative three plus three is equal
to zero
so we have zero is equal to the cube
root of alpha plus the cube root of beta
plus the cube root of gamma
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world's
problems one video at a time